awesome just a quick introduction of who
i am i am the manager of that machine
learning team that's bought if i were
actually music discovery team so we're a
small team focusing on couple of
features related to personalization and
using discovery and another like how to
take our vast catalog and make it
accessible to users so Kristin devil are
here today from this team in case you
have any questions about Spotify or what
we're doing with machine learning I'm
not going to talk that much about
machinery I'm going to focus mainly on
Luigi which is a batch processing
framework that I built together with the
data team over in Stockholm so I guess
that deserves an introduction Spotify is
a swedish company we started in
stockholm i used to work in stockholm
for three years and one theory about two
years ago and i sort of switch roles but
i used to manage their data team over in
stockholm so I used to be involved in a
lot of this stuff and I still kind of
happen because I'm managing yeah I'm
patching Luigi a lot and developing it
and it's open source than six months so
I wanted to go through what it's useful
for well I think you should take a look
at it and how it solves a lot a lot of
pitfalls related build workflows and
especially Hadoop and anything really
where you have a lot of data that you
need a process um just to give you a
background above like why we need this
we Spotify is a online music streaming
service and users stream tracks there's
20 million tracks we have about 25
million active users so that generates a
ton of data denies data but like who
streamed what track where maybe not
weird but what IP what platform what
country how long do stream it did they
skip it
and a lot of that stuff Oh data about
life who log soon who browses what pages
in decline etc etc so that's soon self
is like a building of billions of log
messages that we gave and we want to
process that data so just to mention
like a couple of things we want to build
is topless we want to figure out what
are the most popular tracks when I send
an external we want to reports the
external people so they know how much to
should get paid up do a lot of ad hoc
sirs to figure out like specifically
question of like new features that we
launched we want to do a lot of features
related to machine learning and music
recommendations so that's what our team
booze and the ton of other stuff add
forecast same data warehousing and we
had all of problems building us we've
been doing this for five years so here's
a new cluster our first to do cluster
we've been to do closer for about not
really to do cluster we've actually
replaced it three times now so we have a
new cluster with 200 notes but this is
where it started so I'm going to go
through it like a really naive and
simple example and first do it like the
wrong way all the anti-pattern so if
like how you not should do bad thing and
I should not connect things and build a
workflow so here's a case that's kind of
similar to something we have to do it in
production that's part of so we analyze
this and this is essentially what I just
describes the tupolev like some users
streams some track at some point in time
and just for sake of making is easier
i'm also soon they have the meta data
present so we know that not just the
track they also knows ours so we know
that I SUIM MC Hammer at two o'clock in
the morning
first step is we want to rank this or
sorry the first step is we want that for
each artist we want to figure out how
many times was that so we want to figure
out Rihanna extreme 500,000 times m NN
four hundred thousand times etc for but
100 few hundred thousand artists 100,000
artists so that's different so now we've
aggregated frequencies for all the
artists second step is we want to take
that list of few hundred thousand
artists and we want to take the top ten
and we already know it's going to be
like rihanna eminem and Kanye West but
we want to figure out those top ten we
can also do it by country of course but
essentially all we need to do is like
take the output the top time pretty slow
operation a third and final step we want
to put in some kind of database in this
case I'm going to just show you hype in
Postgres but you can easily imagine
putting a Cassandra or whatever that you
prefer how not to do it I'm going to go
through like the most native way to do
it and show you a bunch of pitfalls and
then next part of presentation is I'm
going to show an overview of how easy
magically solve all these issues so this
is the this is the most stupid way of
doing it put everything on top you have
three steps you want to run you just
trigger down at like the first one at
1am second one at 2am third one at three
this this looks crazy but I've actually
seen some of this code and I've actually
built it myself I'm embarrassed to admit
admit many years ago I don't have to go
into detail about why just it's not a
good approach but a couple of issues are
all this liquid them they're like what
happens if the log files weren't written
before 18 what happens if the previous
job didn't finish what happens if
something crash crashes and you have to
go and manage Lee infected
okay so at least what we could do is we
can put this in a script and we can put
these three steps after each other and
make them functions and just have
readable names for input and output we
meet arguments and that solves the issue
if like dis chaining it right but um and
at least ekron tab entry is going to be
pretty simple okay so now we made
something a little more easy I think
weird this is a little at least a little
bit more maintainable okay so what
happens now someone writes a bug so one
or something screws up there's something
that's broken there's going to be errors
and things are going to crash and what
do you what is that going to what is
that going to cost so I think everyone's
like probably headphones with this you
have some thing creating a file that
takes a while and it crashes in the
middle because there's an integer
overflow or something like that and
suddenly you have this like partial
output and you have to go and clean it
up or even worse you have some other
task leading that partial output and
trying to like do the next run this next
step on it or something like that and
you end up with really bad data and you
have to go in and manually delete
everything and we run it from scratch so
at least one thing we can do is we can
have some kind of try except around and
just delete the output because we know
the output is broken so we should
definitely delete it all right so
problem solved and now let's say we have
two thumbs and we run the first step it
works really well finally no bugs it
finishes put the second step cells
because there's a bug there and we want
to rerun it we fix the bug we think we
want to rerun it we don't want to rerun
the first step again right because we
already created that first step so what
we want to do is we wanted to skip it
okay so that's all so simple so
you can just add like a if not exists
and I think you see what I'm where I'm
getting to like you start adding normal
these dislike boilerplate and that's
essentially what we kept doing for the
first two years and I don't think it's
like a horrible I just think like all
these things add up they add possible
possible traps and error saying it they
add a lot of a necessary code and
boilerplate they don't necessarily want
to deal with um here's like something
that adds even more boilerplate you want
to have some kind of command line
interface to this script so you wrote
the script it's really cool now you
figure oh I actually want to run this
for like arbitrary dates so you throw in
like a small command like parser in this
where you can just provide a date that's
really cool on that's really good but
yeah I'd seen it more code so um you end
up with more and more code maybe you
also want to put in the for loop maybe
you want to have some mechanisms where
it tries to fun and check for the past
seven days and just make sure are the
topless created if they aren't created
it will go back and create lucky circle
topless it would make sure like we have
old like for each date we have a little
topless so this adds even more code and
um nothing horrible again I think this
is this is pretty decent code I just
think there's a lot of boilerplate I
think the end of the day you want to
focus on the algorithms not how they're
connected and like how you parse command
line stuff and like how you write stuff
from input and output and what happens
if something fails so that's why we
started investigating how to build a
framework to do this and we spent a
couple years doing the wrong things we
just actually the third iteration but
going to show you how we think would you
solve a lot of these things
um this is what happens by the way all
these plumbing sucks I think most
programmers don't want to deal with the
plumbing right you want to focus on you
want to run the app you want to
implement the algorithms you don't want
to deal with all this like what happens
to something cracked this how do you
rerun things how do you build command
line interface so all this plumbing
let's just like leave that to framework
let's just focus on the algorithms okay
so plumbing so um so as a programmer
that I think the next question is so if
plumbing soaks what school and I think
graph holograms are kind of cool so
another way to make this more
interesting and fun to think about to
work with is to think of it like these
like workflows as a big graph of things
you want to run so even if this in the
simple case we essentially have three
steps and they're just like a very super
simple graph with four notes and three
edges and this is a little more a larger
graph it's taken from our production
environment shows a couple of stuff it's
not necessary i don't i'm not going to
go in it because what it does but um i
think it's it's an easy way to think
like it's an intuitive way to think
about data plumbing and data workflows
as graphs and i don't think that's a
surprise to most of you i think it's
probably something you're aware of but
it's worth to mention again um okay so i
went through a lot of like minor
pitfalls and like annoying things about
just doing things in a way i'm sure a
lot of you have experience doing things
like this i'm now going to go through
how luigi kind of addresses a lot of
these issues and gives you a framework
to focus on whatever you want to run not
how you deal with failures and building
come outline their face and all that
stuff um so I think it's I think
superficial is a little hard is
described with Louie JS but I think the
best way I can put it is it's sort of
like nate file
where you have like things and you have
dependencies and you specify that in
order to run this thing you need these
other things and these other things may
in turn need other things and you get
this recursive dependency graph where
I'm sorry how's it spelled
I think okay so the question is why
don't we use once I've actually never
heard about it but it's apparently a
build system for Python ah Neville kind
of answered that question he was saying
that it's more focused on compiling
stuff is that correct ok right so again
just because it's a make fall
replacement doesn't mean it's focused on
this area compiling stuff I think the
similarity is mainly license appendices
works and how you specify like I want to
run this but before in order to run this
I need these other things and you need
is dependency so so that's a natural
similarity but I mean it's not it's not
similar to make fault really it's just
that I think that's the easiest way to
put it arm it so so what does it contain
other than that it has look nice on
Hadoop convenience classes in it it
gives you a natural like an easy way to
run MapReduce jobs using streaming so
it's a contains a wrapper around Hadoop
streaming it has a bunch of HDFS
abstractions gives you the atomic file
operations on HDFS stuff like that gives
you attend to you emails if something
crashes it has a migration and some
visualization bunch of other stuff like
that um so going back to the aggregate
artist thing so this was the first step
right we have a big data set containing
all the streams and we want to for each
artist we want to count how many times
did that artist was that artist stream
so this is how you would express it in
OGG so I'm going to try to point out a
couple of interesting things here first
of all every task is essentially a piece
of work and they're all defined by
subclassing that we the abstract liji
task class
so in this case we subclass it and call
it a graffiti artist and that just means
that this is a piece of work that we
want to run it this class defines three
methods which so most tasks will
implement all these three methods
although it depends on what specific sub
positive these three methods out
requires and run specifies first of all
where does it output of this go and in
this case it is hdfs again thing
required it just says like well in order
to run just our great artists I need the
streams data and the third thing run it
specifies like how to actually want this
like what's the code that does this and
another couple of cool things might not
be obvious is you can just open streams
using this and you don't have to care
about if it's an HDFS or local or SCP or
whatever it just magically wraps it and
gives you a stream like object back same
with writing stuff you can just open it
like that and it gives you scream like
object and can write to it and it's
atomic you don't have to think about all
these issues um cool and it also gives
you command line interface so you can
use one script like this and it's
automatically going to expose all the
tasks and you can just run it like this
i'm going to later i'm going to go back
and like add some more complicated stuff
to add dates and parameter system
something um so this was like a very
simple task and in the most basic case
you just subclass the wii u task and
then you implement some specific thing
you want to run in the run method but
there's also a couple of ready-to-use
processed in luigi that you can just
subclass for and one of them is the
MapReduce class that just wraps a dupe
stripping and you can see a simple way
of running a dude job
with very little boilerplate we also
have some other tasks around five jobs
insert data and in Postgres we have some
internal stuff to like move stuff into
Cassandra SCP things are dumb things
from databases and stuff like that and
it's pretty simple to just add new task
types okay so Lu Zhi is at its core a
very abstract this workflow management
tool but as I said it focuses on Hadoop
and it comes with a toolbox for doing a
lot of Hadoop related stuff and one of
it is learning that producing Python it
it's a pretty simple interface I'm going
to show you a code example in one second
so just how long all you need to do is
just implement mapper and reducer it
gives you some other cool things like
it's actually going to go out and fetch
the trace backs from the task wreckers
it's had some other cool things like you
can you can add distributed cache and
combiners and counters and stuff like
that it's sort of like mr. job I don't
know if you use mr. job but it's a
Python framework that Yelp open sourced
and the reason why we decided not to use
mr. job is I'll go back to it later
here's an example of how to run a
MapReduce job in Python so it's pretty
simple to what we just saw before but
instead of just so ask we subclass the
heck job task and we just implement an
acronym deter and these things are going
to run remotely these things are going
to run on your local machine but these
things are going to run on your when you
trigger it is so this is essentially
just work out it just goes through and
just groups things by artists in the
mapper step and then on the review
except you just for each artist you just
sum up the number of streams and
powerful you stop put it so
it's super simple it's like the
canonical example of a MapReduce job
right more count attaching a few jobs
sorry python packages pretty simple you
can do some cool things like in transfer
local state like again this thing will
run locally and this thing's everything
you write to this you said on the object
is going to be accessible in the macro
which one so a couple of features like
that are pretty useful so right so now
we just built the first step in
MapReduce so the second step we still
many around the second step and the
second step which is to take the list of
all artists and just aggregate it sorry
find the top ten one so for each art is
now by now we have a list for like each
artist how many streams to God and at
this point we just want to take that
list and just find the largest 10
entries and just put it some so so again
just just declare so dependency in the
previous step is declares like I'm going
to put this somewhere in this case it's
just a local file and same thing here
you can open things and reads and write
things it's going to be atomic and gives
you streams just like a lot of comedians
added around reading things from HDFS so
hopefully and the third step is just an
example of how you can have other types
of tasks like in this case you can
search something in a postgres so this
is something that we use a lot if maybe
not useful to everyone but it's just an
example of how you can define loftus
that do kinds of different things you
how you can integrate it and your
workflow and do things like inserting
things in a database so in this case we
just define like houston mapping from
columns to to comb the data types
a couple of things like what's the table
and pass for your mobile so now we can
run it and so what happens here is it
sort of works like make fall air we just
say that we want to run the last thing
we just say we want to run the top 10
list and it's going to automatically go
to the top and say well in order to
insert this into the database what kind
of previews steps when you first and
it's going to figure out well I need a
great the artist first and in order to
do that sorry in order to insert the
stuff in a database you need to figure
out the top 10 artists in order to do
that you need to i gave the artist right
so it's going to recursively go back if
you get all the dependencies right and
then it's going to run them in some
water from top to bottom where you
follow the dependency graph so it's
pretty simple so another cool thing is
its entry by doing nothing you can just
launch a running the background these
things are actually going to communicate
with a small rest interface and you're
going to have a webinar face that you
can access which you so see all the
tasks that are running and gives you the
visualization using graph ways so in
this case we have three tasks that I
mentioned in billion times green means
it's finished Blue means it's running
white means it's still to be run at some
point
and then we put it in the database and
this is just what the result looks like
and the cool thing we can actually go in
and just drop the table and we can run
this thing again and it's just going to
run this the last step again because it
already know is that all the previous
stuff already they just have to be run
the last of it because if yer saw it
looks in the database and see it's like
it's the data there if not I'm going to
recreate it so it's going to recreate
the last step you can go ahead and
delete all the data and it's going to
rerun all the three steps um right so
this was a very simple example I'm gonna
go in a detail but like how you can
customize things and add parameters it's
kind of a conceptually interesting way
to customize things but nothing
complicated really so we have these
tasks and maybe you want to add like a
date for this so you just want to be
able to tell lead you that I just don't
want to run this for any specific period
I want to run this for this specific
date right so the way you do this in
luigi is you add all these parameters in
the class scope and it just tells you
that like these these some fields are
all like attributes that are belong to
the tasks and there it customizable any
couple of nice things like if you create
um if you instantiate this task it's
going to be able to reap the the
attributes it gives you a constructor
for free and it also gives you a parser
like a mounted lining for free so you
can specify a date and it's going to
parse it and you're going to be able to
read it from here so this week an idea
of what I'm talking about here here's
here's the previous example where I add
dates so in this case the streams it's
an external thing it's it's it's like
the logs that are synchronized from our
production environment we customize them
by date so we can refer to like a
specific log a specific collection of
log files
and actually here we specified date
interval which is I'll just date but
arrange it okay you know well I want to
run this a great artist job but I want
to run this for range of dates so in the
requires method I just say well I need
all these all these individual dates in
the date range but you don't even have
to change in any of the code if it's a
MapReduce code if it's a MapReduce job
it's actually going to be the same code
you just have to change it requires
nothing and and here's what the
visualization looks like in this case we
we run this with a week here it's gonna
it's going to require dependency and all
day and all the individual dates in that
week from Monday to Sunday okay so a
couple more features the cool thing but
it's that it says it actually knows all
the tasks and their dependencies it
gives you a very like very simple way to
just add paralyzation by just using the
flag workers and it can figure out
because I have a hold is how i have this
entire dependency graph you can
essentially figure out what things i can
run in in the pet plane so in this case
we say well we want to run with Paola's
and it's going to run these three in
parallel just like a simple feature um
not a cool feature is that catching
trace box and just emailing them come
straight out of the box you don't need
to set up anything you just need to
configure an email address and
everything that fills is going to be
sent to your email address and even if
something fails on a Hadoop node is
going to go out there and fetch the
trace back from the sass tracker and
email it to you which is kind of nice in
this case we had a typo another kind of
subtle thing is also it deals with the
case where you try to run the same tasks
simultaneously in two different places
so maybe two workflows try to trigger
the same thing that does something we
had a lot of crumpet so the same server
that does the visualizations also figure
sod what things are looking it already
knows everything that's running
everywhere we can say like sorry I'm
already running this you can't run this
anywhere else so it has a simple locking
mechanisms to avoid running the same
thing to us the same screen shot but I
just wanted to point out what what's
going on here here's here's the example
from our production environment most of
this is Hadoop jobs but down here is a
couple of Cassandra insertion jobs so
it's going to run a bunch of Hadoop jobs
in this chain and then trickle down all
the way to the end and here i think this
point is going to insert the resultant
cassandra and green thing means that the
data is already available the orange
thing means that there is some external
task but we don't have the data for it
could be like some log file but doesn't
exist yet so it basically is like in
this case there's actually nothing you
can run cuz like you can see that you
just track below dependencies like all
the white things at some point that you
can back trace it back to the orange
thing so you can't really run anything
here but it's a nice visualize like how
did the different depends fit together
here's here's what happens if you start
running this with like roughly five or
ten thousand jobs a day or other kind of
based on at this point and this is a
screenshot from our web interface but
most of the time it's so big that we
can't even render it I think we need to
spend some more time figuring out how to
render large graphs but I mean that's
kind of a nice problem because it means
that we use we use you for a lot of
stuff and it's really clean Ian that
only problem is that we run in for so
much stuff that you can't render it at
this point
um so I wanted to go through a couple of
misconceptions about Luigi or rather
like frequently asked like a lot of
common understandings about lee ji
because a lot of people ask me like
house is similar from house is different
from X and I'm going to go through a
couple of examples of X so there's a
package not produce Python hold mr. job
and Lugi is not trying to replace Mr job
gives you a really convenient way to one
epic jobs in Python using Hadoop
streaming it gives you amazon easy to
support and stuff like that luigi tries
to do a lot more other stuff don't like
just wanting to do jobs Luigi this is on
how you declare all these dependencies
and I can build like arbiters things
that aren't just running Hadoop jobs it
could be pointing from databases or SC
peeing files around or whatnot um lucia
doesn't really help you with the
scalability you can't really spark with
an existing algorithm and just throw it
like lychee doesn't really help you
scale it up again what it does is just
once you figure out how to scale it up
how do you how do you break it on an
appt jobs or some other scalability
framework you want to use at that point
Louise you can help you it's like chain
aldi step sink in a complex graph you
know it's also not a way to do like
filter for certain apps or like group
buys and joining data set not producing
itself great way to do it hey get hive
are like really good high-level
abstractions do it would lead us is to
connect all these things so luigi
happily ella gates a lot of that
low-level mapping and filtering and
stuff like that to to some other tool
that does that job much better
it is sort of like easy though so the
only so I wanted to go through why I
don't like easy and here's the summary
and I googled losing example and i found
this enormous xml file and actually want
to see at some point if i can rewrite
this in Louisiana I think it's going to
be like five lines probably um cool so I
mentioned a lot of stuff about Luigi by
now I hope you know it's a great way to
divide appendices between things and run
things and bull up cool workflows just
mention like a wider range of wide array
of flicks use it for Hadoop streaming
it's like probably ninety percent of all
tasks in our workflow but we also use
the trigger like Java jobs hive and pig
Crais we do a lot of local stuff like I
work with a lot of machine learning so
one of the tasks could be like well we
have all this data we train we fit some
kind of regression model and then write
the output to some foul maybe it takes
like an hour to do that regression then
you want to integrate it in your
workflow um exporting important from
databases postcodes and sandra and ftp
ting things and things like that are
things we use it for and yeah and it's
it's open source so go and clone it and
started right away it's been open source
for six months something like that it's
built by mainly by mean another guy
coleus freighter is in Stockholm and
actually I feel bad he actually did this
most of this presentation I actually
stole it from him where empathy is using
it there's a couple of people from which
is cool and yeah so I think you should
check it out
mentioning a couple of like future plans
we definitely want to add pig support we
do have pigs board in our internal
version both have an open source site
yet we won't happen ec2 we also have
some like horrible code to do that but I
don't think it's ready to be open source
yet we used to Center a lot so we want
to sort some support for that too again
this is more about like creating a tool
box around Luigi not really like adding
specific features to lee ji because i
think there's like two different aspects
of it and that's it so thanks a lot and
we're also hiring so you should start on
questions
I'm sorry so the question is it is the
penalty for the resolution framework are
there ever cyclic whole dependencies I
mean I think the question almost by
definition has to be no because how can
you run it if it's like if there's a
cycle right you need to start somewhere
I mean we do definitely have recursive
tasks so something can depend on a
previous version of itself so you can
have like some aggregated data set that
depends on the previous version of
itself plus some Delta or something like
that so where one of the parameters
change but cyclic all dependencies it's
I don't I don't know how that would
arise in a normal workflow hope that
makes sense more questions
are so the question is how do we handle
errors that occur in external things and
that's that's up to like each specific
task to declare I think it's we try to
parse as much as we can from so a lot of
this like essentially just like runs
like a subprocess and just like when
something like raps like a command and a
lot of these tasks to the largest extent
possible we try to parse the output and
if any if it returns with a not zero
exit status we try to race the whole
output as an exception or things like
that so so then it's going to go back
and like send an email containing here's
the stuff from javis of telling you
something hopefully that might be useful
more questions
so the question is how do we deal with
different file formats there is some
support for file formats well like we do
have some some ways to just easily gzip
things like you can you can just say
well here's a file on my local disk and
it's gzipped and you're going to be able
to just read it like a normal filestream
we we use a bro so with we have some
internal stuff that takes care of like
that wraps the HDFS file object and just
does a decoding on the fly so if you use
like some non standard format you
probably have to figure out how to like
subclass the HDFS object and add support
for serialization and deserialization
more questions either if you go first
so the question is how do how do we
check whether something has been run so
if you if you go back to the code where
it was that so essentially if you want
to figure out if something is wrong uses
check the output if it exists or not and
there's actually four like non file
system tasks there's ways to like like a
custom complete method so you can like
essentially query the database and see
if some entry exists or not so it
doesn't have to be a file on this but in
most cases it is a file on disk so you
can do simplement output and it's going
to check whether that exists
you
so the question is like how will we we
recommend using weegy for non-native
stuff maybe relational databases I think
you should use for everything because I
think it's really helpful if you have
like more than a handful tasks you want
to put them in some kind of a workflow
that being said the only thing that we
support right now is postgres but that's
just like one of that's just like a
simple tasks and it's it's really like
super simple to just take the Luigi task
and subclass it and and customize it in
ways you wanted to make it kind of like
an independent task that has some kind
of check to see it what it's been
running on so if you end up adding
support for my sequel feel free to
submit a pull request the awesome more
questions questions I can't have a
timeout if something is taking too long
I think again that's one of those things
works up to each task to define you can
maybe if you're running like some long
running process in the background you'd
have to implement things that just sit
and raise exception after certain amount
of time that's up to each task and it
could be like if you're running a Hadoop
job like it will be up to that specific
subclass define a timer
so the question is how do we schedule
things to run like the Leafs the simple
question or the simple way to do it we
we often have this a rapper task that
just declares like everything that has
to be one for certain dates so for if we
have some work flow that is supposed to
generate recommendations every night we
can say that again the day we have this
like dummy tasks that just requires that
all this type of recommendation has to
be created and this type in this type in
this type and decide so you just have to
say well go and create this dummy task
and then it's going to schedule
everything backwards so I think that's
the most that's the easiest way to
schedule things a lot of things
so the question is can you schedule
continues things up yes and no it's a
little trickier than that you there's
some crude support for that but it's
it's mainly meant to like you run a
script and then it's going to like go
back and like sort of like may foula
check all the dependencies and and see
what it has to do and usually that means
that whatever it can run is going to run
but if it can't find anything is just
going to exit and you're going to have
to try again later so you usually just
put it in cron and say try every minute
it done but there is some support
because you can have I mentioned this
thing about the locking service you can
have task like running on different
processes and have this locking service
and that one can actually that one has
some information and what what's
finishing so I think in principle some
of some simple cases would be handled by
that but more complicated cases there's
not support for yet but it would be cool
to have some kind of push mechanism to
all select trigger things based on
availability yep um so the question is
what's the roadmap I think throw my
rapid right now is mainly adding support
for just like just building out the
toolbox I really want to add pic support
I think easy to support would be really
nice too there's a couple of more like
from the mental changes like how can we
use this to run things in more like a
real time and stuff like that but those
are more like I think long-term things I
don't know if we're going to
realistically start working on that now
but it's again it's open source so you
know feel free to submit a pull request
at some point if you have some cool
stuff you want add more questions
on I didn't hear all sorry can you
repeat that
Ric the question is does each step right
up persistent storage right now that's
the I think that's like the base case
you can we can have there's some ways
you can't support like having
intermediate things there are just
temporary files and there's some
semantics to support temporary files
that would that will automatically
delete themselves when they go out of
scope it's a little tricky to use it in
practice I think that's one of the small
things i want to make easier so if you
have like a long chain of jobs you can
have like pepper outputs in the beloved
and just at the end you will have some
persist about what we actually use in
practice is we put all of those things
special directory and then we just have
like a simple conscripted discos and
then deletes it and that's actually kind
of nice because it means that if
something crashes in the honk chain you
can resume it as long as you don't
presume it like then it's going to be
wiped out
oh so the question is is there support
for transactions I think their idea is
that every task is like independent of
other tasks so like it there are
transactions but only on like a file
system level so even if so I think so in
most cases your task only writes one
single output so in that case you're
going to get transaction safety on that
level because you only going to write
like one output file to HDFS or locally
or write something to sequel or
something like that and in that case you
can guarantee transaction safety but if
you have like several tasks ah I don't
think that's like within like the
conceptual idea of Luigi because the
idea is that task is kind of independent
on whatever goes on the streams so at
least X can finish but if Y breaks that
that should affect whether X gets commit
or not that makes sense
um the question is the best so it's are
just two different interface the rest on
your face and is web supper dead renders
an SVG but um something want to do
actually you asked about the roadmap
something I forgot to mention we really
wanted to figure out how to draw large
graph so we don't get this stuff so
we've been working on some JavaScript
draft rendering libraries and I think I
think we really want to do is like have
look at web interface like the
jobtracker where you can see like here's
the very thing that's running by who and
how much time is what's the eat eat and
stuff like that and that's something
really want to do soon
okay cool you see a d3 yes yeah yeah
we've looked at d3.js as a way of
visualizing these cuts and I think
there's some kind of prototype
internally that we just have to clean up
and make a little more pretty
ah so the question all this would really
help you define UD apps you define
functions in hive and pig that the short
answer is it doesn't at all right now
but we actually do ask cool ideas and
like how you could provide like Python
methods and it would compile into Jason
and use those methods from your pig
script I think that the insanely cool
but but that's sort of on the road man
yeah
I see so so the question is how to
define more complicated semantics for
when something is complete and the
dancer is every task can define an
optional complete method it defaults to
just like querying the output method and
checking whether that exists but you can
actually implement them complete method
so for instance when we synchronize our
logs from production machines we have
certain like checkpoints that we write
that says like we've queried all the
machines it's safe to like process that
data because we're one hundred percent
sure we have all the data up until 1am
now and in the same way you can
implement custom complete methods I
guess there's a lot of questions so
maybe we should and in here but um
thanks a lot